how are you brother okay now you don't
know Goodfellas I saw the words you had
to say about Prince what Prince meant to
you now I know you perform at least one
print song in in your set but did you
ever meet him never met him never met
him saw the concert never met him up you
know who he actually cut raspberry beret
back in the day did you yeah did but
that didn't make on on any of the album
did no no now do you have a good friend
do you have to get permission from
Prince to record raspberry beret no you
know we didn't we read you know we
didn't get permission I think you know I
wouldn't cut pro / and I was asked a
million times to cut it but I wouldn't
cut it out of out of be respect
respectful Prince because it's like oh
it's already been done perfectly you can
play it live but what record but what do
you so what prince songs do you perform
in concert I do wha I retired purple
rain after the last two tours ago but I
guess about to break it back absolutely
well you have a purple rain is it really
do it's so funny man you know you
playing this big country shown you come
back out and everybody's like waiting
here we gonna play and you start playing
proper raining to see the people's faces
just really go oh my god is good out
that was always a great moment but yeah
I'm breaking it back out that door yeah
there's just I don't know if you can
emulate what Prince did I don't know
like people do covers but you know he
was such an like to uh as an artist so
big that motor guy was 52 you know he
was like King Kong up there oh
absolutely i mean you can't even come
close to what President just the the
subtle dance moves he had and the way
his band was such a pan and they don't
thing that no was taught that that I
haven't seen anybody talk about is his
guitar playing and he's one of the best
guitar players in the world and and he
was just man the talent that guy had
just over the top but you also had
somebody who was a great musician I
think that that's what's lost nowadays
that is a writer / do
sir but also he could pick up just about
any instrument and he can make it his
that I mean that awful it's different
and like you said that's that's a lost
art now you know people you know you see
a lot of singers out there like even me
I'm a singer I you know you know like I
don't play the guitar i play with the
guitar and Brent could pick like you
said he you know you'd seen play
keyboards in it in a cheapo your money
he was a drummer first first mainly you
know his first century was drums and
simply but he was yet he was that guy
that just transcended music how would he
be perceived welcomed not welcome if he
was coming out today with with that
style what he was doing oh so I think
it's if he came up today he would be
just big because his style transcended
time what he did he was like you know he
was a great dancer a great singer and
like you said a great producer a great
songwriter and I even think he I mean
some of those right i think you know
purple rain come on today and still be a
hit but that whole album could come out
like let's go crazy and those songs
would fit right into what happened today
and he was dealing man he just say he
was the word legend has used way too
much more exam yea r alleged your genius
yeah he was your support he was a 10
savant you know he was a guy that like
you said he just picked up instrument
and you give him bike I mean any
instrument you give him an hour so he's
playing it like you know he's played it
as a life and he was yeah Prince was one
of my I mean mainly want to be a
musician maybe wanna be in a band he I
mean is a young african-american kid
growing up in South Carolina well that
controversy record came out you don't
know you know looking all pretty because
to talk about that was huge did you want
to have a jheri curl of course I was
ever we just my mom can't afford it I
ya'll said to have the activator too
didn't you see you couldn't get you
couldn't display the 64 the Jericho you
also have to scale that my fact afford
that if you could go back in time see
any any i'ma say performer because I'm
not gonna say band because maybe that's
unfair because people pick the Beatles
but if I said you know Hendrix Michael
Jackson again did you ever see Michael
Jackson
I did see I did see that michael jackson
was in the victory tour with his
brothers that was unbelievable
unbelievable who was the second best
performer in the Jackson 5 um definitely
uh Jermaine Jermaine wanted to be
Michael so bad you could tell that on
stage oh absolutely absolutely if you
don't be yeah yeah oh so you saw okay so
if you can go back and see one performer
so let's say it's an anybody Sinatra Bob
Marley Hendrix is anybody that would
stand Elvis I think if i could see one
performers definitely a tie between IT
marley or the beatles yeah absolutely if
i can just see one show of somebody yeah
cuz like I I still kick myself of that
ever got to see marley because you see
those constitute man i would have been
right in the middle of that but see the
Beals would have been oh I mean you know
okay I mean I get chills thinking about
it do you really believe that the prince
did not he had never heard the song
while my guitar gently weeps when he
performed at the rock and roll hall of
fame when George Harrison was inducted
posthumously in that guitar solo he's
that's what you know that that legend
has it that Prince did not heed not he
wasn't familiar with the song they gave
him the music to that the day before and
then he goes up there and kills oh
absolutely i believe that totally yeah i
totally because yeah I'm sure prince was
you know big army guy and I mean guitar
gently weeps the great song but if you
aren't really into the Beatles or in the
you know rock radio if I meant it wasn't
some you heard a lot but yet principles
of genius man I've had to get to give it
to him an hour with daughter killed it
yes do you believe that Kobe was
actually able to he played the piano he
didn't take lessons but he wanted to
learn a song to be able to play for his
wife did you do you hear this story no
yeah I don't know what this song was but
Kobe wanted to be able to perform it for
his wife so he played it by ear I can
believe that yeah oh it's a blue
moonlight sonata by Beethoven
and all an easy one right so Cogan says
that he learned it by ear I could
believe that that didn't leave that is
dedicated to inset on the ppl yeah I
could believe that could you learn
Beethoven's moonlight sonata man I can't
learn you know let her cry yeah I love
when you forget lyrics in concert that's
that's one of my favorites because I do
like to get you a little banged up
before you go on stage and then when you
get out there and all of a sudden you go
wait let's say what's the next course
I'm going oh my gosh I did it always
seems to happen when you're around hi I
do do you have lyrics printed out no
absolutely you've never done that never
had a cheat now I know like you know
maybe like if we're doing some show like
like you know the thing we do in my nest
of the Masters where we play with a
bunch of bands sometimes I might have a
cheat sheet there but if you talk about
me getting up doing a show no never and
and is hooting the Blowfish recording an
album not anytime soon oh they're not
okay now and not recording I mean oh
that sounded like a definite no that
wasn't even like you know they leave it
open the possibility come on give us a
little hope there or we will we will
just you know I heard a rumor that was
gonna be this year and next year I don't
think I'm doing anything so no no not
interested and you're not there not
touring there's none of that you just
like occasionally you do a benefit show
and that's it yeah I mean we will tour
we will do a record but you know I just
haven't I'm not until we I tell you
we're not doing anything so I think we
have pretty great song and you know so
not not not any time soon okay I hope
sports jeopardy and I'm sure if I get
you and two other musicians to do sports
trivia are you in I'm good cuz I'm women
absolutely okay but who give me two
other musicians that I can have up there
I'll get me and uh get Dave Matthews cuz
I don't think table no luck no Dave's
not gonna know anything exactly Dave
Dave knows another how about Tim McGraw
I'll till you kill a girl be good me Tim
and uh let's see he loves i gotta-i
on it who snoop snoop I'm in a min i'll
take that right now i'll take that right
now you would be the favorite in my mind
yeah yeah what if i knows i know some
thought sports that sometimes i go how
do I know that how about jay z oj z yeah
yeah yeah get Jay Z because maybe I'm
get on his record after that yeah I get
you see do you have you met Jay Z no
I've never met baby I had good i love it
south carolina ah you poor god you poor
guy how are you dolphins looking heading
into the draft here you feel pretty good
Super Bowl the host bully and rule over
here yeah yeah they're going to attend
right no we're winning it and game clock
is gonna win that's a champion football
so you know this could be my year the
Gamecocks are winning and the go okay
who has a better chance of of winning um
I have a better chance of winning the
side young so I'll see you I'll see you
here in a couple of weeks right looking
forward to men you have no idea how much
I'm looking forward to that all right
brother good to talk to you thanks good
talking to you the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience